les terroristes de l'ira frappe très
fort sur le sol anglais une bombe dans
une caserne elle a fait 11 morts et 22
blessés
les boîtes noires du dc-10 retrouver et
rapatrié en france elles permettront
peut-être de comprendre le drame du
denver surprise à beyrouth le général
chrétien michel aoun a semble-t-il cd il
accepte le plan de la ligue arabe pour
le liban le conflit peugeot dans
l'impasse il reprendra lundi
reportage que les salariés de peugeot
qui préfèrent maintenant travailler en
suisse
bonsoir mais avant de développer ses
titres ceci à propos de la prise
d'otages de liège qui dure depuis
presque une semaine il y à quelques
minutes à peine les deux fillettes ont
été libérés par les gangsters l'une
après l'autre on pressentait depuis hier
que le dénouement de cette prise
d'otages approcher toute la journée des
négociations se sont poursuivies pour la
libération dans un premier temps des
deux enfants nous en sommes là
puisqu'elles sont libérés je voulais
d'il ya quelques minutes à peine
alors dès que nous aurons les images de
cette libération et la correspondance de
notre envoyé spécial bruno gex bien sûr
nous reviendrons sur ce sujet dans le
courant de ce journal avant tout cela le
dc10 c'est une commission denquête
française qui va s'occuper de la sphère
du dc10 qui s'est écrasé dans le désert
avant-hier pour aider à comprendre le
drame elle pourra se servir des deux
boîtes noires de l'appareil qui ont été
retrouvés dans le désert les deux boîtes
noires vont être rapatrié le plus
rapidement possible en france et on a
appris cet après midi que les corps des
victimes seraient eux aussi rapatrier
directement en france pour que
l'identification soit plus rapide
maintenant avec les images les plus
récentes prises dans le dévers on sert
mieux peut-être les causes de la
catastrophe
dominique verdeilhan comme couché sur le
sable le cockpit du dc-10 bien que très
endommagé la cabine de pilotage est
reconnaissable de même que le train
d'atterrissage avant à près de 10 km de
là l'arrière de l'avion avec la dérive
et une partie du 3e réacteur entre les
deux cette empreinte noire a provoqué
sans doute par l'explosion des
réservoirs de kérosène
au milieu de cet amas de ferraille l'on
distingue le coeur d'une pure
bean et puis surtout l'insoutenable des
corps disloqué comme se met sur une
superficie de 50 kilomètres carrés
première constatation des équipes de
secours les corps des pilotes et des
passager avant ont été découverts
intacts
contrairement à ce qui était assis à
l'arrière de l'appareil
donc si déflagration il ya eu ce cela se
situerait davantage vers l'arrière
d'appareils l'une des deux boîtes noires
devrait arriver à paris demain mais
c'est l'examen des débris qui
déterminera l'origine de la catastrophe
sur le terrain le travail est difficile
la température est de 45 degrés les
hommes doivent boire entre 15 et 20
litres d'eau par jour
cet après midi les premiers corps ont
été ramenés à n'djamena les plus
difficilement reconnaissables seront
identifiés à paris on appris dans
l'après midi que tous les avions
français pas seulement ceux du téat et
est maintenant placé sous une
surveillance particulière et un contrôle
très strict des bagages c'est le
ministre des transports qui l'a dit tout
à l'heure
d'autre part les lives et a coupé court
aux rumeurs en affirmant que la france
n'était au courant d'aucun préparatifs
d'attentât qui la vie vraie ou qui
viserait ses intérêts il n'y a pas eu de
menaces précises a dit l'elysée
et puis enfin pour être complet sur ce
chapitre j'ajoute que demain ce sera
journée de deuil à l'aéroport charles de
gaulle
une manifestation silencieuse aura lieu
à 14 heures l'ira relance le terrorisme
sur le sol anglais avec la plus grande
violence les terroristes d'irlande du
nord ont en effet revendiqué l'attentât
de deals une petite ville dans le sud
est de l'angleterre une bombe qui ce
matin exploser dans un immeuble d'une
caserne de la marine l'immeuble s'est
effondré
il y à 11 morts 22 blessés et un disparu
c'est le plus grave attentat depuis
longtemps philippe harrouard est en
grande bretagne explications
c'était la salle de repos des nouvelles
recrues de la fanfare des royal marines
le bâtiment de trois étages s'est
écroulé après l'explosion d'une bombe ce
matin peu après 9 heures à la caserne de
deals dans lequel sous les décombres
plusieurs militaires des jeunes de 20
ans pour la plupart afin de localiser
les blessés les pompiers utilisent des
détecteurs thermiques
les secouristes vont dégager une dizaine
de cadars les victimes de ce nouvel
attentat signé de l'ira dans un sinistre
communiqué l'organisation terroriste
faisant allusion à la récente visite de
madame thatcher en ulster ajoute nous
nous avons visité les royal marines dans
lequel aux alentours de la caserne les
vitres des maisons ont volé en éclats
les voisins s'étonne de ce que l'on
pénétrait facilement dans cette école de
musique dont le contrôle était assurée
par une compagnie privée une cible bien
facile pour les terroristes
la police avec deux commandos de l'irak
composée de quatre ou cinq hommes chacun
était prêt à opérer sur le sol
britannique
la charge est sans doute de poser les
bombes l'autre spécialisée dans le
mitraillage
mais il est très difficile de les
localiser car ils sont autonomes
discret et surtout bien entraînés à leur
travail
le terrorisme ces derniers mois il ira
surtout frappé contre des bases où des
soldats britanniques en europe allemagne
ou pays-bas
le dernier attentat meurtrier en grande
bretagne remonte à août 1988
dans une caverne du nord de londres il y
avait eu un mort et neuf blessés
avec celui-ci adil lira marque à sa
manière le 20e anniversaire de l'arrivée
des troupes britanniques en irlande du
nord
d'autres actions sont à cran
hugo refuse de mourir il s'agit du
cyclone bien sûr et en avançant il ne
perd pas de sa violence la nuit dernière
il a touché les côtes américaines et
s'est acharnée sur la caroline du sud
dévastant tout sur son passage
une fois de plus la ville de charleston
a été particulièrement touchée philippe
boisserie
comme prévu hugo a touché ce matin les
états unis comme redouté il a tué au
moins trois personnes ont déjà trouvé la
mort dont un bébé de 6 mois
écrasé par la chute d'un arbre sur sa
maison au réveil les habitants de
caroline ne pouvait que constater la
folie dévastatrice du cyclone charleston
ville symbole du charme sudiste n'a pas
résisté aux assauts du vent
une trentaine de maisons deux fois
centenaire ont été soufflées même la
mairie vieille de cent quatre-vingt-huit
ans a été décapitée
des dizaines de milliers de personnes
ont dû être évacuées vers des lieux plus
clément certains ayant refusé de partir
le bilan risque donc de s'alourdir
loin de la désolation terrestre un autre
spectacle envoûtant celui offert par un
avion de la météorologie engouffrés dans
l'oeil du cyclone
un mur de plusieurs kilomètres de nuages
au fond le tourbillon informations en
bas cette dépression d'aspe si pacifique
est en train de répandre la terreur oui
et pendant ce temps là la guadeloupe
panse ses plaies
le passage du cyclone n'est plus qu'un
souvenir mais les traces qu'il a
laissées ne sont pas près de s'effacer
hier nous avons parlé les cultures
ravagées cela va appauvrir terriblement
l'économie de l'île autre secteur
sinistré le tourisme bien sûr hôtels et
bungalows sont détruits là encore c'est
l'économie qu'il faut reconstruire
rémy roche et pascal stelletta reportage
voici gosier l'une des perles du
tourisme guadeloupéen omer soleil marina
cocotiers un petit paradis transformer
en enfer en une nuit cyclone
comme à saint françois et à sainte anne
les hôtels sont bien sûr en bord de mer
ils ont donc été les premiers à essuyer
la puissance du cyclone pour la plupart
ils sont aujourd'hui fermées hors d'état
conséquence les restaurant de la marina
marche au ralenti pour autant qu'il
puisse fonctionner quand les hôtels sont
vides
il n'y a pas grand monde pour goûter à
la langouste à la créole
je veux ouvrir parce que certains
personnes mais je m'appelle et pour
réseau des tables et j'ai ouvert contre
un peu mon degré et je ne travaille très
très peu j'ai eu sud de clientèle il ya
soit s'était facilement à 20% des
marchés à potentiel
pourtant tout le monde s'y met pour
tenter de gommer au plus vite les
blessures du cyclone
pas question de baisser les bras pas
question surtout d'hypothéquer l'image
vacances soleil plages de la guadeloupe
et contacts que nous avons eus tour
opérateur nous amène à penser que les
tour opérateurs n'ont en rien annuler le
programme qu'ils avaient sur la voix de
lou et qu'ils attendent simplement de
savoir quand nous leur donnerons le feu
vert pour recommencer à vendre la
destination guadeloupe ce que nous
allons faire très bien fait propose
optimiste rassurant on jure ici que tout
sera à nouveau prêt à la mi décembre
pour le démarrage traditionnelle de la
pleine saison touristique car personne
ne peut oublier que le tourisme pour la
guadeloupe c'est la ressource numéro un
le conflit des inspecteurs des impôts
ils ont bien du mal à intéresser les
français à leur problème inconsciemment
au fond de nous mêmes on ne peut pas
s'empêcher de penser que s'il n'y avait
pas d'inspecteurs des impôts il n'y
aurait peut-être pas d'impôt du tout
évidemment ça ne marche pas comme ça
les inspecteurs des impôts ce sont des
salariés comme les autres et le conflit
dure depuis un moment il se durcit men
il y avait aujourd'hui de très
nombreuses manifestations en province et
plus de 8000 personnes ont défilé à
paris
la longueur de la grève provoquant plus
des effets tout à fait inattendue sur
l'économie jean pierre métivier et jean
louis goût serre ont enquêté de l'or
invendables des bijoux qui n'ont pas
encore reçu le fameux points sont à tête
d'aigle celui qui garantit l'ordre de 18
carats et pour cause le service des
poinçons pétanque
dépend de l'administration des impôts
alors la production des bijoutiers
fabricant s'accumulent dans leurs
coffres
je ne peux plus vivre et mes clients sur
le marché intérieur est plus grave
encore je ne peux plus livrer mes
clients à l'exportation et en
particulier mes clients japonais qui
sont extrêmement rigoureux sur le plan
des délais et qui vont purement et
simplement annulé leurs commandes en
fait d'exportations on ne connaîtra même
pas ce mois ci le chiffre du commerce
extérieur ce qui le calcul sont aussi en
grève
tout semble pétrifié dans les
perceptions l'échec du dernier tiers
n'ont pas tous été encaissés et dans ce
seul coffre-fort recettes parisiennes un
loin de 3000 chèque de tva approchant le
milliard de francs lui les tags de toute
façon compte tenu du manque de
recouvrement en matière de tva est
obligé de faire financer certaines de
ces dépenses par la banque de france et
cette situation peut durer un certain
temps mais ne peut pas s'éterniser
étant donné que même pour l'état fait
grève coûte très cher cela peut être
gênant quand l'état emprunte 50
départements seraient touchés par la
grève selon les syndicats
les agents réclament 1500 francs par
mois déçu ce soir par une rencontre avec
un collaborateur de michel rocard
les grévistes annoncent un durcissement
du conflit une autre état à de vignette
auto le 1er novembre
peugeot l'a encore le conflit se
poursuit et il reprendra la semaine
prochaine à mulhouse une centaine de
grévistes ont bloqué la porte par où
sortent les voitures et les grévistes
ont poursuivi leur mouvement d' appel à
la solidarité à mulhouse à sochaux et à
montbéliard
chez peugeot il y a aussi des ouvriers
notamment des ouvriers qualifiés qui ne
se contente pas de faire la grève
ils sont carrément parti pour aller où
et bien pour aller en suisse je n'ai pas
très loin une soixantaine déjà ont pris
le chemin et ils ont fait la comparaison
entre leurs nouveaux et leur ancien
travail
françoise joly pierre laurent kunst en
reportage 4 heures du matin poste
frontière de huningue entre la france et
la suisse
ce minibus et celui de l'entreprise
suisse où elle une usine d'emballage du
canton d'argovie
à son bord huit frontaliers alsaciens
quatre sont des anciens ouvriers deux
jours dont christian la creuse qui a
travaillé plus de 11 ans dans l'usiné de
mulhouse
que j'ai un ami qui est parti et quand
j'ai vu son salaire ça décide alors
c'est difficile de trouver du travail en
suisse non des cons on a employé peugeot
pratiquement fait sur le champ sans
effet en discussion pourquoi le savoir
faire le travail qu'on a fait d'abord
sont intéressés c'est grâce à ce
certificat de formation professionnelle
qui s'est fait embaucher
aujourd'hui ils gagnent d'outing francs
par mois le double de son ancien salaire
vous vous en connaissez beaucoup des
gens qui sont partis lui au moins une
dizaine puis-je depuis le début de
l'année au moins 25 personnes de partie
des professionnels qualifiés et plus
tous les copains que je connais cattrall
de permis pour les partir en suisse et
ça se passe comment six mains ça se
passe très bien on est des hommes n'est
pas des numéros que ma peugeot des
violoneux joue bien avant de quitter
peugeot il ya quinze jours christian la
creuse a fait une semaine de grève
une ultime protestation dit il pour tout
ce qu'il a ressenti comme des
humiliations au mois de juillet donc
déjà j'ai reçu une lettre comme quoi il
était un très bon élément
j'avais jamais l'absentéisme et je vais
droit à une visite du linéaire vaut pas
gratuit tout le monde tout ce qu'ils ont
eu selon lui les gens aujourd'hui en
suisse
il travaille 40 heures par semaine mais
il affirme faire beaucoup moins d'heures
que chez peugeot allait venir le samedi
matin
et si on va fuser les thérapies au
bureau comme quoi vu notre position est
obligé de venir travailler le samedi
matin on est obligé parce qu'ils avaient
besoin de nous
sur dix est non il aurait plus besoin de
nous nous change de place chaque jour
question la creuse suit très
attentivement l'évolution du conflit
sa femme son beau frère travaille
toujours dans la fiom 2 retour à liège
tout de suite je vous le disais en
commençant ce journal les deux fillettes
qui étaient retenus en otages par trois
gangsters ont été libérés leur mère est
toujours prisonnière tout de suite nous
retrouvons à liège notre envoyé spécial
bruno gex la situation est à peine une
heure philippe clerc a relâché la
première fillette
une ambulance s'est alors rendu près de
la villa où les trois otages se trouvent
depuis presque une semaine maintenant la
moitié de la rançon alors été déposés
devant la maison 4 millions de francs
pêche puis même scénario quelques
minutes plus tard avec la deuxième ville
gaël et françoise joly 10 et 13 ans et
est immédiatement examiné par les
médecins belges
elles font en bonne santé quant à
philippe delaire il détient toujours la
mère marie madeleine jury dans la villa
n'a pas encore choisi de fuir à bord de
la mer c est qu on lui a fournie il
faudra bien choisir soit la hollande
situe à 30 km la france à 40 km ou bien
la rfa voilà fait le dénouement le début
en tout cas du dénouement de cette prise
d'otages qui durait je vous le rappelle
depuis presque une semaine
au chapitre économique un gros succès
pour l'industrie française michelin
vient de racheter uniroyal le fabricant
français s'est payé la firme américaine
qui était l'un de ses concurrents
principaux pour un milliard et demi de
dollars soit dans à peu près 10
milliards de francs ainsi le fabricant
français de pneumatiques devient le
numéro un mondial dans son domaine
devant goodyear économie toujours avec
la fin d'une semaine importante c'est
celle de la présentation du budget l'une
des priorités c'est vous le savez le
logement est la priorité des priorités
c'est le logement des plus défavorisés
par exemple ceux qui sont obligés de
squatter les immeubles parce qu'ils ne
peuvent pas faire autrement
j'en paye eux
belleville la plus grande zone de
rénovation urbaine de paris
dans ce quartier populaire les immeubles
anciens acquis d'autorité par la ville
font place à des logements neufs hlm ou
autres jamais au bénéfice des gens du
quartier et nouveaux occupants les
classes moyennes des mal logés on en
trouve ici des maliens occupe cet hlm où
la ville avait refusé de les reloger
autre squat par la même rue un immeuble
ancien partiellement occupés par des
jeunes étudiants et chômeurs et des
ménages avec enfants sans logement
stable
cinq enfants vivent ici depuis un mois
avec leur mère mahdia occuper un
logement sans bail dans un autre
quartier paris un jour elle a réclamé
une quittance la gérante la mise à la
rue j'ai été hébergée quelques jours
chez des amis qui me soutenaient et
depuis au moins on a essayé de me
trouver ça donc ici ce squat où vous
vous trouvez voilà c'est grâce aux
copains des mal-logés tout ça et tout
tous les tous les jeunes qui m'ont
soutenu et ils ont fait ça surtout pour
les enfants sont ils ont eu pitié de mes
enfants
ils voulaient pas voir des enfants
dehors j'ai beau essayer tenter d'avoir
un hlm et tout ça mais pour moi c'était
très très difficile très difficile à des
familles en détresse qui en dix ans
d'attenté n'a jamais pu avoir un
logement
dès l'an prochain les choses vont
changer
les organismes d'hébergement agréés
pourront acquérir des immeubles comme
celui-ci et prendre en charge leurs
habitants objectif éviter le squat où
l'exil en banlieue de dix mille familles
par an surprise à beyrouth le général
aoun accepte le plan de la ligue arabe
le général aoun c'est le général
chrétien
après des mois d'une guerre sans merci
où beyrouth a été encore détruite un peu
plus si c'est possible
le chef du clan chrétien donc le général
aoun accepté le plan mise au point par
la ligue arabe
alors qu'est ce que cela signifie dans
le conflit libanais patricia cost
le général aoun a hésité quatre jours
puis il a cédé
il a dit oui à l'algérien ibrahimi
porteur du plan de paix proposé par le
maroc l'arabie saoudite et l'algérie le
général aoun a cédé sur un point
essentiel celui dont il avait fait son
cheval de bataille
la présence syrienne au liban ceux-ci
n'évacuerons beyrouth et sa région que
dans deux ans si ici et là le plan
comporte sept points dont deux
principaux l'aspect sécurité le blocus
maritime du réduit chrétien sera levé et
l'aéroport ouvert toute importation
d'armes devront être arrêtés une
commission de sécurité doit y veiller
or la composition de cette commission ne
répondent pas aux voeux du général aoun
elle ne comportera pas de syriens sur le
plan politique les députés devront se
réunir rapidement pour établir un
programme de réformes
à l'ombre des canons syrien les
dissidents chinois s'organisent pour la
première fois depuis les événements de
pékin ce qu'ils ont pu en tout cas à
s'enfuir à l'étranger
ils se sont rassemblés c'était à paris
il tente de créer un mouvement politique
serré donc ce matin à la sorbonne
jérôme baugnies la sorbonne était
chinoise ce matin accueillant le plus
grand rassemblement de dissidents en
exil rescapés de la répression
venus du monde entier pour fonder la
fédération pour la démocratie en chine
une minute de silence à la mémoire des
victimes de la place tiananmen pour le
gouvernement chinois
tous ces hommes sont des criminels
contre-révolutionnaires le processus
démocratique en chine est un carrefour
proclame le leader étudiant voir kaixi
nous sommes tous ici pour tirer les
conséquences du mas à cette date restera
une date historique toute l'europe
intellectuelle et politique est à ce
rendez vous y compris une délégation de
solidarnosc particulièrement applaudi la
pologne a pour ces chinois valeur
d'exemple ils veulent eux aussi créer
une force politique en dehors du parti
comme il l'a des derniers dissidents
arrivé en france et cet homme soutien au
camp de scénariste et journaliste c'est
très populaire
le pays est toujours écrasé par la
terreur explique tim eux ont réussi à
fuir mais n'oublient pas leurs camarades
en
donner chaque année à la veille du 1er
octobre anniversaire de la prise du
pouvoir par mao les exécutions sommaires
se multiplient dans les prisons nous
allons voir maintenant d'autres
informations internationales de ce jeudi
est d'abord la colombie avec la
démission de la ministre colombienne de
la justice il s'agit de cette jeune
femme de 32 ans qui avait impressionné
le monde entier par sa détermination à
lutter contre les truands de la drogue
eh bien elle renonce à me consignes et
monica de greef aura tenu un peu plus de
deux mois
ces menaces de mort proférées contre
elle et sa famille par les trafiquants
de drogue auront eu raison de sa
détermination
en trois ans la colombie a connu 8 me
faut de la justice
arrivé dans le wyoming de edouard
chevardnadzé james baker les chefs des
diplomaties se greffent les américaines
tenteront de trouver la date d'un
prochain sommet soviéto américain somme
est jugée nécessaire
hier à washington par le ministre
soviétique des affaires étrangères
edouard chevardnadzé et le président
russe
le tribunal de marieville tennessee rend
sa décision concernant la sphère des
embryons congelés
la mère pourra disposer 17 ans brio
malgré l'opposition du père dont elle
est aujourd'hui divorcée
dans cette affaire le juge d liang a
considéré que la vie commence dès la
conception à sakina aujourd'hui dans sa
ferme d'afrique du sud de france votent
le père de l'ancienne championne de
cross-country zola budd
l'homme a été retrouvé dans une mare de
sang sa voiture et son physique et ses
volées
négociations pour l'achat de mirage 2000
par le koweït les pourparlers sont en
cours
l'indicé mardi prochain l'émir du koweït
en visite en france entretiendra avec
françois mitterrand ce civils tués hier
à piney dans l'aube
leur voiture est entrée en collision
avec un char allemand participant aux
manoeuvres franco-allemande champagne 89
en signe de deuil et festivités marquant
la fin de ses opérations pour ses filles
annulé
la bourse de paris aujourd'hui hausse de
0 90% de l'indicateur de tendance cours
officiel du dollar si france 57 phase où
l'on reparle de la sphère des irlandais
de vincennes cet étang 82 l'arrestation
de présumés terroristes
une arrestation qui est vite devenu un
imbroglio politico-judiciaire sur ce
sujet un homme jean michel baud qui a
été au coeur de la sphère sort un livre
explosif et cet homme sera ce soir
l'invité de bernard pivot dans
apostrophe c'est à 21h30 ne manquez pas
ça hervé hervé brusini pardon rappel
cette affaire depuis sept ans ils n'ont
jamais tourné la page ni jean michel
bull gendarmes ni bernard jega
l'informateur jean michel beau lui à
présent est retraité élevé au grade de
lieutenant colonel
au soir du 28 août 80 de jean michel
beau assumer la responsabilité
judiciaire de l'opération sur ordres du
capitaine prouteau de la cellule
élyséenne paul barril et ses hommes
arrêtent 3 irlande et soupçonnés de
préparer des attentats
mais bien vite l'histoire tourne au
scandale les armes et explosifs
retrouvés dans l'appartement aurait été
déposée par les enquêteurs eux-mêmes
aucune règle de procédure n'aurait été
respectée jean michel baud a décidé d'en
finir en livrant sa vérité de la faire
avec ce livre un brûlot contre l'état où
le capitaine prouteau est accusé de
braver toutes les irrégularités ont fait
tenir on va pas se laisser emmerder par
des terroristes auraient dit prouteau
selon l'auteur un livre règlement de
compte avec aussi une autre exigence
soit intrinsèquement j'ai fauté il n'est
pas question d'un non lieu je ne repense
on voudrait jamais la deuxième façon
c'est d'être renvoyé devant un tribunal
en mois depuis six ans je n'arrive pas à
obtenir l'arrestation soit conduite à
charge et à décharge pour finir par les
m'expliquer devant un tribunal
c'est ce que je réclame quant à bernard
jega il a voulu s'expatrie en israël
c'est lui qui avait indiqué la piste des
irlandais aux autorités lui aussi comme
jean michel baud est inculpé il n'a
qu'une idée en tête le jugement de la
façon de donner un élan décisif à une
procédure qui est truqué je crois que
c'est une situation qui est absolument
inadmissible parce que les dégâts sont
considérables pas seulement sur le plan
politique sur un plan de policiers mais
aussi sur un plan humain il y à 7 ans
les télex annoncé l'arrestation des
irlandais aujourd'hui les patients ne
sont toujours pas éteinte
le sport maintenant avec les essais du
grand prix de formule 1 au portugal
meilleur temps comme d'habitude ayrton
senna sur sa mclaren bien sûr devant
derrière sur ferrari prost et oui n'est
que 5e cette fois et d'ailleurs il est
devancé la quatrième place entre autres
par la williams de ricardo patrese il
faut dire que patres dispose maintenant
comme good scène d'une toute nouvelle
voiture
c'est la nouvelle williams renault
lionel chamoulaud frank williams se
soulager sa voiture est enfin prête la
nouvelle williams est arrivé trois mois
après la date prévue
elle s'appelle la fw31 son objectif
battre les ferrari et les mclaren
aujourd'hui c'était sa première sortie
alors premier constat selon je suis sûr
c'est qu'on a une voiture qui est
meilleur que l'ancien maintenant
meilleur de combien je sais pas encore
le dire le potentiel et pendant exploité
on n'a pas encore trouvé des bons
réglages donc ça va venir petit à petit
souci principal équilibrer la voiture la
plus grande originalité réside dans le
dessein de l'avant reste à trouver les
bons réglages
l'ensemble la suspension avant sur
l'ancien coq était très très peu rigide
ici c'est l'inversé très très très
rigide ce qui fait qu'on allait y aurait
pas les problèmes mais beaucoup de mises
au point à faire avec notamment le train
arrière qui se dérobe assez facilement
dans les grandes courbes est en train de
travailler là-dessus mais je le
potentiel est là et on sent que la
voiture a vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de
potentiel il faut pouvoir l'exploiter et
la mettre au point assez vite maintenant
pour l'adaptation du renault sur le
nouveau châssis pas de problème le
moteur français et lui tout à fait au
point
du côté de la région attend donc
beaucoup de la nouvelle voiture
donc le niveau actuel de la voiture est
suffisant pour dire qu'elle est bien né
et c'est très encourageant je crois pour
la suite
la seule façon de prouver que cette auto
est au top c'est d'être à la hauteur des
mclaren de senna et prost les valeurs
référence du moment
voilà je pense que je suis sur même
qu'il y ait un tiercé je pense que c'est
un quarté + dessus pas sûr alors on va
regarder les pronostics de pierrette
brès il y a dix sept partants pirette
nous propose de jouer le 11 le 4 las le
17 le strunc le 16 le 13 et le 18 c'est
demain à auteuil il s'agit donc de
course de thé voilà avant de terminer
complètement ce journal je vous rappelle
la principale information que je vous
donnais tout au début de ce journal il
s'agit de la prise d'otages de thil en
belgique c'est près de liège les deux
fillettes détenus en otage à tilff ont
donc été libérés tout à l'heure vers
19h30
gaël qui a 10 ans et françoise qui a 13
ans sont donc libres et elles sont en
bonne santé semble-t-il leur mère
malheureusement restent prisonnières des
trois gangsters parmi eux vous savez il
ya le fameux gangster français philippe
delaire la prise d'otage je vous le
rappelle durée depuis maintenant presque
une semaine
voilà les rendez vous de la soirée tout
de suite bien sûr vous avez la météo
avec laurent cabrol c'était le premier
week-end d'automne et il sera beau et
n'oubliez pas d'ailleurs mes enfants
vous en reparlera qui est demain soir
samedi soir dans la nuit de samedi à
dimanche on change d'heure pour revenir
à l'heure d'hiver
voilà ensuite eh bien vous aurez
n'oubliez pas non plus l'excellent
feuilleton que antenne 2 vous offre
attendez je m'interromps un instant car
on m'appelle au téléphone
voilà une information très précis sur la
prise d'otage de thil près de liège je
vous le disais tout à l'heure à
l'instant même on apprend que les
ravisseurs viennent de sortir la prise
d'otages est donc apparemment en train
de se dénouer
en ce moment même vous en saurez plus
donc dans la dernière édition du journal
qui vers 23 heures sera présenté par
henri sannier auparavant n'oubliez pas
l'excellent feuilleton le premier
épisode ce soir du nouveau feuilleton
que vous offre en termes de ça s'appelle
mon
dernier rêve sera pour vous c'est une
vie romancée de chateaubriand avec
francis huster et anouk aimée ensuite
apostrophe nous en avons déjà parlé
c'est à 21h30 c'est bernard pivot
voilà le rendez vous pour ce week-end
pour vos informateurs et bien ce sont
comme d'habitude daniel bilalian bt
dureau philippe gassot excellent week
end sur antenne 2 bien sûr